hey 42 here you can find some truly
weird and wonderful things in the
guinness book of records gianzia has the
longest eyelashes in the world
nick sterberl has the longest tongue
and shraddha chilal holds the frankly
disgusting record for the longest
fingernails on a single hand ram singh
chauhan has the longest mustache
mement ozyurek has the biggest nose
and the one you've all been waiting for
a man called akira yakakura is the proud
owner of the world's most gigantic [ __ ]
roach wait what did you think i was
going to say in case you're interested
this girthy cockroach is 10 centimeters
long with a 20 centimeter wingspan and
it can be found preserved in mr
yakigura's private collection in
yamagata japan
coincidentally considering the context
in which i brought it up the world's
biggest cockroach belongs to the species
mega lablatta lungi penis
sometimes these things are just meant to
be
as incredible as all these things are in
my opinion one record in that venerable
book of guinness stands head and
shoulders above the rest in more ways
than one
the record i'm referring to belongs to
an unassuming man by the name of robert
pershing wadlow who was born in alton
illinois in 1918.
he was quite simply the tallest human
being
ever to have lived
there are several things that make this
record so remarkable first it was set
almost a hundred years ago when the
average height for an american male was
under five foot seven around three
inches shorter than it is today
second considering the sample size we're
talking about literally billions upon
billions of people throughout history
wadlow holds this record by a surprising
distance
he was more than two clear inches taller
than the second tallest person ever
another american by the name of john
rogan
the final reason wadlow's record is so
amazing is simple
there's a very good chance
it will never be broken but more on that
at the end of the video
the tallest person amongst the almost 8
billion human beings on planet earth
today is a turkish man by the name of
sultan cousin when you think about it
it's quite a feat to be the tallest
person alive we live in an era when
there are more people than ever before
and when the average adult is taller
than at any point in history but
here's the crazy thing
sultan cousin tallest man on earth is
more than eight inches shorter than
robert wadlow was when he died
there are estimated to be somewhere in
the region of two thousand eight hundred
seven footers alive today one of those
is shaquille o'neal arguably the most
physically imposing basketball player
the nba has ever seen
here he is standing next to full-grown
adult man kevin hart
this on the other hand is shaq standing
next to a life-size statue of the
tallest man in history
yeah i make that about nipple height
next to a man mountain like shaq wadlow
still looks huge
next to human-sized humans he hardly
looks real
at first glance this looks like a
picture of a man standing in the middle
of a group of children
but no that's just robert hanging out
with his family
the man on the end is his dad
he's just under six feet which was
considered relatively tall for the eva
the funny thing is robert came into this
world a perfectly normal sized baby
not that he stayed that way for long in
the first six months of his life he grew
at a rate of more than two inches per
month by the time he was half a year old
he was about the size of your average
two-year-old
and when he took his first steps a month
before his first birthday he found
himself eye to eye with the local
five-year-olds
to say robert was an unusual looking
child doesn't really do him justice
there might not have ever been a kid
quite like him
by the time he turned four he was taller
than the average adult woman of the day
and by six he was about the size of your
average man
when he started first grade he was
comfortably taller than his teacher
robert continued to grow at an almost
unbelievable rate throughout his
childhood topping six feet by the age of
eight and seven feet by the age of
twelve by this point robert's family had
started to realize their son wasn't just
a big strong glad who ate all his greens
he was genuinely abnormal
and so they took him to the local
hospital for a checkup
which was when they found out what was
really causing him to grow so fast
astonishingly high levels of human
growth hormone cursing through his body
due to an enlarged pituitary gland
there is nothing that could be done
about the condition the pituitary gland
is inconveniently located at the base of
the brain meaning accessing it is a
dangerous business
robert's doctors didn't dare to operate
for fear of killing him outright as he
approached his teenage years robert had
grown so outlandishly tall that he was
becoming something of a minor celebrity
at 12 he met heavyweight boxing champion
primo kanera
standing at six feet six inches tall
corner was an absolute giant in his day
nicknamed the ambling alp he still holds
the record for the most wins by knockout
of any heavyweight champion in history
corner had spent his entire life being
the bigger man not just in the ring but
basically everywhere except when he met
the boy the papers had started calling
the alton giant
twelve-year-old robert wadlow made quite
the impression on canara he described
him as the biggest human being he'd ever
seen that was no doubt true but little
did the ambling alp know that robert
still had another two feet of growing to
do
at 15 years of age robert was seven foot
ten
that's a good three inches taller than
gorgey morrison the tallest man to ever
play in the nba
and by the time he graduated from high
school at 17 he stood up frankly
ridiculous eight foot three inches tall
and his remarkable growth was showing no
signs of abating
robert was a bright guy but despite
having left school with good grades he
found himself facing something of a
problem
growing up he'd harbored ambitions of
becoming a lawyer but eventually he had
to accept the fact that he was simply
too big for his chosen career
that might sound ridiculous jobs don't
come with theme park ride style height
restrictions
but robert was so tall the normal rules
of life simply didn't apply to him
if you're able-bodied and of a fairly
standard height you probably take the
ease at which you navigate the world
each day for granted
but for extremely tall people things
aren't always so straightforward anyone
over six feet six will learn pretty
early on to stoop a little lower when
approaching the average door frame to
avoid banging their head two roberts the
average door frame hardly got past his
navel and he was taller than most
ceilings
working at a standard desk was just out
of the question and almost all the items
you need to work in the 1930s office job
pens and pencils a typewriter a pretty
young secretary to have an affair with
were all too small for his hands which
incidentally were the longest ever
measured
he even had to invent a new crab-like
technique for walking upstairs because
his feet also the longest in history
were too big to fit on the steps
even something as simple as using the
toilet was incredibly difficult
if you ascribe to the theory that the
average bloke has pretty shoddy aim when
it comes to answering the call of nature
just imagine how much worse it would be
if we all went to the loo standing
halfway up a ladder
in the end robert had little choice but
to accept that a regular job just wasn't
an option
still there was one career path that was
always going to welcome him with open
arms and painfully craned necks
the circus
the world's famous ringling brothers
came calling in 1936 when robert was
just 18
and they were both pleasantly surprised
and absolutely delighted when the
world's tallest man politely accepted
their offer
whilst on the face of it joining the
circus might seem like a somewhat
degrading thing to do for a bright young
man with no actual circus skills
robert never saw it that way
he somehow managed to keep the whole
thing pretty low-key
he always wore his own clothes flatly
refusing all attempts to get him into a
giant top hat and tails
and he only ever appeared in the center
ring never the sideshow
the circus along with robert's work as
an ambassador for the international shoe
company that made his custom size 37a
shoes
gave robert the chance to travel around
the country
from the back of the family car which
his father had customized to accommodate
him the olsen giant toured 41 states and
about 800 towns and cities in the space
of just a few years
despite his incredible height robert
flatly refused to use a wheelchair at
any point in his life
choosing instead to support his
over-taxed legs with a set of metal
braces
it was an admirable decision
using a wheelchair would have made
robert's life easier in a lot of ways
but eventually it came back to bite him
literally
one of the many downsides of being as
big as robert wadlow is that you tend to
lose feeling in your feet and legs
and so when robert's leg brace started
to rub against his ankle one day in the
summer of 1940
he didn't even notice
allowing the abrasion to develop into a
blister before he even knew there was a
problem the blister had become infected
and robert was seriously ill
antibiotics weren't widely available at
the time and so robert was rushed to
hospital and given a blood transfusion
but
it was already too late
he died in his sleep nine days later
it was a desperately sad and sudden end
to a life that was far too short
the universe really does have a sick
sense of irony
as luck would have it 18 days before
robert passed away his height was
officially measured by doctors
and it's this number that's considered
to be the world record today
just before his death robert wadlow
stood almost nine feet tall
it's a figure so unreal it probably
wouldn't even be believed today if there
weren't so many surviving photos to back
it up
there's something undeniably fascinating
about a human being that large
and it seems that fascination didn't
wear off with robert's death more than
40 000 people came to pay their respects
at his funeral
where certain modifications had to be
made to allow things to proceed as
normal well as normal as possible when
laying a literal giants to rest
robert was buried in a custom-made
10-foot coffin that was so long it hung
out the back of the hearse
it was heavy too
robert was a trim man throughout his
life but even a fairly skinny almost
nine footer is going to weigh a bit he
was comfortably over 30 stone when he
died almost 450 pounds
and it took 18 pallbearers to carry him
three times the usual number
i mentioned at the start of this video
that robert wadlow's record as the
tallest human being ever to live will
probably never be broken
but that isn't because he attains the
maximum height our species can reach
although it's thought he was probably
pretty close to what is physically
possible based on our physiology
no
the reason the record will probably
never be broken is that no one will ever
be allowed to grow so tall again
there are several conditions that cause
people to grow up normally large
but these days all of them are treatable
to some degree or another take the
world's current tallest man for example
sultan's incredible growth was caused by
a tumor in his pituitary gland
in 2010 he underwent successful surgery
to remove it
halting his growth almost overnight
you might think sooner or later someone
with gigantism will come along and
actively try to beat the record by
refusing surgery
yeah it's possible but pretty unlikely
human beings just aren't designed to get
as big as robert wadlow was
pretty much everyone who suffers from
gigantism dies young usually due to some
form of heart failure from the strain of
trying to pump blood around such an
enormous body
refusing treatment could potentially
give someone a chance of topping
wadlow's record one day
but it would also be a death sentence
not to mention the fact that being nine
feet tall isn't exactly something most
people aspire to if we take disease out
of the equation it's almost
inconceivable that anyone will ever
reach the nine-foot mark
the tallest person to ever live who
didn't suffer from some form of
gigantism
is thought to be a scottish-born
canadian man by the name of angus
mccaskill
at seven foot nine he was truly massive
but still comfortably over a foot
shorter than the olton giant
robert wadlow didn't live a long life
but it's unlikely he will ever be
forgotten today more than a hundred
years after his birth the pictures and
videos that survive of him are just as
flat-out ridiculous as they ever were
in many of the pictures i've shown you
in this video robert was well short of
his full height of 8 feet 11 inches and
he still looks photoshopped
ultimately it doesn't really matter
whether or not the record will ever be
broken
robert wadlow stood 8 feet 11 inches
tall even if our descendants are
destined to be genetically modified
20-foot demigods
that will always be a truly remarkable
thing
thanks for watching